now we've talked a bit about how to
share your prototype with people who
might help you build it better one other
very common kind of presentation is a
demo of your prototype these demos come
in all shapes and sizes from a 30 second
elevator pitch to a two-hour
presentation you'll want to spend some
time thinking about how to best talk
about your prototype and show it to
various audiences these presentations do
have some fundamentals you can start
with your elevator pitch should quickly
explain what your app does who you do it
for and why it is important you've
already made an elevator pitch if you've
been through that course but it'd be a
great idea to take some time now to
refine that elevator pitch after all if
you've properly adapted your app using
the marketing course it's likely the who
is changed since you first made that
pitch and if you've been prototyping
well it's possible that the what has
changed as well take a moment to revisit
your elevator pitch now and check the
box when you're done